Coffee a lot of different tweets have a
little walk a lot of water coffee
machine and snack machine is your best
friend here and coca-cola because the
question is why you stay wake up until
5:00 in the morning so this is my
driving force first first of all
yes RF is one of only four high-energy
synchrotrons in the world as our name
suggests we are the European synchrotron
radiation facility we mostly produce
x-rays running 24 hours around the clock
used and visited by thousands of
researchers from all over the world we
are investigating a photo sensor protein
so we have a 24 hour shift today
and we brought 120 crystals with us that
we want to measure what x-ray to collect
the data set I expect that we need the
whole 24 hours to measure all of them so
we will not sleep I came here because
you cannot do this kind of experiment in
laboratory and synchrotron facilities in
Europe are not everywhere and so we are
going here to study why the color is
changing on paintings what are the
chemical reaction so it's afternoon we
are going to study a series of fragments
taken by the painting scream biomarker
we have about 8,000 scientists coming
every year to the es RF from all sorts
of fields physics chemistry biology
maybe do the structure this electrode
here I'm that absorption on metal ganic
framework material science nanoscience
little crystal phases metalloproteins by
x-ray absorption and emission
spectroscopy museums bringing precious
artifacts we have alien apologists so it
can be a lot of people here so now it's
half half-past seven
when did we start with this project
after lunch so it I think it took us now
five hours to measure one data set we
have 90 crystals left and we will check
them crystal object crystal tell
tomorrow morning 9:00 a.m. he and I we
are the night shift we are working here
from 7 o'clock in the evening to 8
o'clock in the morning beam time is
expensive and rare so we use every
minute we can and we watch every step
the Machine does so we are here just to
check that the robot is working and this
moving then we can go on so here we can
we'll see if the robot is changing
Sandford see no way didn't work I think
I have to walk in silence
okay I don't know I what time is it it's
too late to call him we will lose a nice
one boy
you guys are still here what's been
happening
so we are very happy we could measure
another dataset for mutant or we had no
data set before yeah so and now we are
going on taking the next
I am Peter Staley and I'm from the State
University of Denmark from the it's
called a sorry I forgot our name I'm too
tired I got up at 6:30 yesterday
you're quite tired but also we are
calibrating on a high of success because
I'm sorry about the data are interesting
so every now and then there is something
which is exciting you're going on now
cannot console this rifle this is the
worst time any to to speak that because
I'm tired
so yesterday night we the problem so
this morning I call the engineer we fix
this problem so now we are just here
waiting the first thing is working ok
you see our movie ok so it's working I'm
quite relieved now so experiment can
start again well the truth at work here
before us the team I just left a couple
hours ago now we are here and working on
probably completely different projects
and now we have 24 hours of beam time